now mr president on an entirely
different matter
of course we also anticipate that
another totally different very serious
item will be heading
the senate's way soon
the senate will have to address some of
the deepest institutional questions
contemplated by our constitution
we'll have to decide whether we're going
to safeguard core governing traditions
or let short-term partisan rage
overcome them back in december
i explained how house democrats sprint
into the most rushed least fair
and least thorough impeachment inquiry
in american history
has jeopardized the foundations of our
system
of government
last spring speaker pelosi told the
country quote
impeachment is so divisive to the
country that unless there's something so
compelling and overwhelming and
bipartisan
i don't think we should go down that
path
that was the speaker less than a year
ago
back in 1998 when democrats were busy
defending president clinton congressman
jerry nadler said
there must never be a narrowly voted
impeachment or an impeachment
substantially supported by one of our
major political parties and largely
opposed by the other
such an impeachment would lack
legitimacy said
congressman jerry adler 20 years ago
that was obviously standard when the
democrat was in the white house
but ultimately house democrats cared
more about attacking president trump
than keeping their promises so they
rushed through a slapdash
investigation they decided not to bother
with the standard legal processes for
pursuing witnesses and evidence
i don't have time to do that
chairman adam schiff told the entire
country on national television that
getting court decisions takes a long
time
he didn't want to wait
it takes a long time to go to court
so they just plowed ahead plowed right
ahead
with a historically weak case and
impeached a duly elected president with
votes from just
one just one political party
democrats have left trump derangement
syndrome
develop into a kind of dangerous
partisan fever that our founding fathers
were afraid of and then mr president
just before the holidays this sad
spectacle
took another unusual turn
as soon as the partisan impeachment
votes had finished
the prosecutors began to develop cold
feet
instead of sending the articles to the
senate they flinched
they flanged that's right
the same people who just spent weeks
screaming that impeachment was so
serious and so urgent
that he couldn't wait for due process
now decided it could wait indefinitely
while they check the political winds
and look for some new talking points
this is yet another situation where the
house democrats have blown right past
the specific warnings of our founding
fathers
alexander hamilton specifically warned
about the dangers
of a quote procrastinated determination
of the charges
in an impeachment he explained it would
not be fair to the accused and it would
be dangerous for the country
speaker pelosi apparently does not care
her conference is behaving exactly like
the quote
intemperate or designing majority in the
house of representatives
that hamilton warned might abuse the
impeachment
power
so as house democrats continue their
political delay they're searching
desperately
for some new talking points to help them
deflect
blame for what they've done
we've heard it claimed that the same
house democrats who botched their own
process
should get to reach over here into the
senate
and dictate our process
we've heard claims that it's a problem
that i've discussed trial
mechanics with the white house even as
my counterpart the democratic leader is
openly coordinating political strategy
with a speaker
who some might call the prosecution
so it's okay to have consultation with
the prosecution but not
apparently with the defendant
oh and we've heard claims that any
senators who've formed opinions about
house democrats irresponsible and
unprecedented actions
as they played out in the view of the
entire nation
should be disqualified from the next
phase
obviously mr president this is nonsense
nonsense let me clarify
senate rules and senate history for
those
who may be confused first
about this fantasy that the speaker of
the house will get to hand design the
trial proceedings in the senate
that's obviously a non-starter
what i've consistently said is pretty
simple
the structure for this impeachment trial
should track
with the structure of the clinton trial
we have a precedent here that means
two phases first
back in 1999 the senate passed a
unanimous
bipartisan resolution 100 to nothing
that set up the initial logistics
like briefs opening arguments
and senator questions
it stayed silent on mid-trial questions
such as witnesses
until the trial was actually underway
that was approved 100 to nothing
somewhat predictably things started to
diverge along party lines when we
considered those
later procedural questions but the
initial resolution
laying out the first half of the trial
was approved
100 to nothing
i believe we should simply repeat that
unanimous bipartisan precedent this time
as well that's my position
president trump should get the same
treatment that every single senator
thought was fair for president clinton
just like 20 years ago we should address
mid-trial questions such as witnesses
after briefs
opening arguments senator questions
and other relevant motions fair
is fair now
let's discuss these lectures about how
senators should do our jobs
the oath that senators take in
impeachment trials to
quote do impartial justice according to
the constitution
and laws end quote has never
meant that senators should wall
themselves off from the biggest news
story in the nation
and completely ignore what the house had
been doing
the oath has never meant that senators
check
all of their political judgment at the
door
and strip away all of our independent
judgment
about what is best for the nation
it has never meant that and it never
could
the framers debated whether to give the
power to trial impeachments to a court
or to the senate and decided on the
senate precisely
because impeachment is not a narrow
legal
question impeachment is not
a narrow legal question
but a deeply political one as well
hamilton said this explicitly in
federalist
65. impeachment requires the senate to
address both legal questions about what
has been proved
and political questions about what the
common good of our nation
requires senators do not cease to be
senators
just because the house sends us articles
of impeachment our job
remains the same to represent our states
our constituents and our nation's best
interest
in the great matters of our time
that is our obligation whether we are
voting on legislation
nominations or the verdict
in an impeachment
president clinton had actually committed
a felony
if democrats actually believed in the
narrow sense of impartiality
they've now adopted as a talking point
then every single one of them would have
voted to remove president clinton from
office
oh no but instead a majority of the
senate decided that removing president
clinton despite his proven and actual
crimes
would not best serve the nation
mr president they made a political
judgment
and by the way back then
leading democrats had zero
zero objections to senators speaking out
before the trial
the current democratic leader
senator schumer was running for the
senate
during the house impeachment process
back in 1998
he voted against the articles both in
the house judiciary committee and on the
house floor
and a major part of his
senate campaign that you're listening to
this
was literally promising new yorkers in
advance
in advance that he would vote to acquit
president clinton
people ask if it was appropriate to him
to prejudge like that
he dismissed the question saying quote
this is not a criminal trial
but something the founding fathers
decided to put in a body that was
susceptible to the whims of politics
that was the democratic leader in the 98
senate campaign
that was the newly sworn in senator
schumer in 1999.
a few weeks later during the trial
itself
democratic senator tom harkin
successfully objected to the use of the
word jurors
to describe senators because the analogy
to a narrow legal proceeding
was so inappropriate according
just senator harkin
so so look mr president
i respect our friends across the aisle
but it appears that one symptom
of trump derangement syndrome is also a
bad case of amnesia
a bad case of amnesia
and no member of this body needs
condescending lectures on fairness
from house democrats who just rushed
through
the most unfair impeachment in modern
history
or lectures on impartiality from
senators who happily prejudged the case
with president clinton
and simply change their standards to
suit the political winds
look anyone who knows american history
or understands the constitution knows
that a senator's role in an impeachment
trial is nothing nothing
like the job of jurors in the legal
system
the very things that make the senate the
right form to settle impeachment
would disqualify all of us
in an ordinary trial all of us would be
disqualified
in an ordinary trial
like many americans senators have paid
great attention to the facts
and the arguments that house democrats
have rolled out publicly before the
nation
many of us personally know the parties
involved on both sides
look this is a political body
we do not stand apart from the issues of
the day
it is our job to be deeply
engaged in those issues
but and this is critical
the senate is unique by design
the framers built the senate to provide
a check
against short-termism the runaway
passions
and the demon of faction that hamilton
warned
would extend this scepter over the house
of representatives
at certain seasons
we exist because the founders wanted an
institution that could stop
momentary hysterias and partisan
passions
from damaging our republic
an institution that could be thoughtful
be sober
and take the long view
and that is why the constitution puts
the impeachment trial in this place
not because senators should pretend they
are uninformed unopinionated or
disinterested in the long-term political
questions
that an impeachment of the president
poses
but precisely because we are informed
we are opinionated and we can take up
these weighty questions
that is the meaning of the oath we take
that is the task that lies before us
impartial justice means making up our
minds
on the right basis it means putting
aside purely reflexive partisanship and
putting aside personal relationships
and animosities it means
coolly considering the facts the house
has presented
and then rendering the verdict that we
believe is best for our states
our constitution and our way of life
it means seeing clearly
not what some might wish the house of
representatives had
proven but what they actually have
or have not proven
it means looking past a single news
cycle to see how overturning an election
would reverberate
for generations
so look you better believe senators have
started forming opinions about these
critical questions over the last
weeks and months we sure have
especially in light of the
precedent-breaking theatrics
that house democrats chose to engage in
but here's where we are mr president
their turn is over
they've done enough damage
it's the senate's turn now to render
sober judgment
as the framers envision
but we can't hold a trial without the
articles
the senate's old rules don't provide for
that
so for now we're content to continue the
ordinary business of the senate
while house democrats continue to
flounder
for now but if they ever muster the
courage to stand behind their slap dash
work product
and transmit their articles to the
senate
it will then be time for the united
states senate
to fulfill our founding purpose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the clerk will report the nomination
nomination small business administration
javita carranza of illinois to be
administrator
i sent a closure motion on the desk a
clerical report
closure motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of javita
carranza of illinois
to be an administrator of the small
business administration signed by 17
senators as follows
i was consent the reason as we wait
without objection
as consent the mandatory quorum call be
waived without objection
i ask unanimous consensus center for
seed legislative session being a period
of morning businesses senators committed
to speak their invoke to 10 minutes each
without objection i understand there's a
bill at the desk to do a second reading
the clerk will recite the bill for the
second time
s 3148 a bill to amend the controlled
substances act
to list fentanyl-related substances as
schedule 1 controlled substances
in order to place the bill on the count
on the provision of rule 14 i would
object to further proceeding
an objection being heard the bill will
be placed on the calendar
i understand the chair received a letter
of resignation
of the former senator johnny isaacson of
georgia which was effective at 5 pm on
tuesday december 31st 2019
the distinguished leader is correct i
ask you nano content the letter be
considered as having been read and that
it be spread upon the journal and
printed the record
without objection
i need to do anything
now mr president i ask unanimous consent
when the center completes his business
today at a journal till 3 p.m monday
january the 6th
further that following the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings to be
approved to date
the time for the two leaders will be
reserved their use later in the day and
morning business be closed
further following leader remarks the
senate proceed to executive session and
resume consideration of the carranza
nomination finally that the cloture
motion filed during today's session
arriving at 5 30
monday without objection
i suggest that before the clerk
will call the roll mr alexander
mr president the distinguished minority
leader is recognized thank you mr
president now mr president i just heard
leader mcconnell
i ask unanimous consent that the quorum
be dispensed with
without objection now mr president i
just heard leader mcconnell speak for 30
minutes
on the subject of the president's
impeachment
there was a lot of finger pointing name
calling and misreading of history
but not a single argument or discussion
about the issue that's holding up a
senate trial
whether there will be witnesses and
documents
not one mention he has no good argument
against having witnesses and documents
so he resorts to these subterfuges
i'll have more to say on impeachment
momentarily but i first want to address
the issue of iran
last night the united states conducted a
military operation
designed to kill major general qasim
suleimani
a notorious terrorist no one
should shed a tear over his death
the operation against solemani in iraq
was conducted however
without specific authorization and any
advance notification or consultation
with congress
i'm a member of the gang of eight which
is typically briefed in advance of
operations of this level of significance
we were not the lack of advanced
consultation and transparency with
congress
was put in the constitution or the
rather the
need for advance consultation and
transparency with congress was put in
the constitution for a reason
because the lack of advance consultation
and transparency with congress
can lead to hasty and ill-considered
decisions
when the security of the nation is at
stake
decisions must not be made in a vacuum
the framers of the constitution gave war
powers to the legislature and made the
executive the commander-in-chief
for the precise reason of forcing the
two branches of
government to consult with one another
when it came
to matters of war and of peace
[Applause]
it is paramount for administrations to
get an outside view
to prevent group think and rash action
to be asked probing questions not from
your inner
and often insulated circle but from
others
particularly congress which forces an
administration
before it acts to answer very serious
questions
the administration did not consult in
this case
and i fear that those very serious
questions
have not been answered and may not be
fully
considered among those questions
what was the legal basis for conducting
this operation
and how far does that legal basis extend
iran has many dangerous surrogates in
the region
and a whole range of possible responses
which responses do we expect which are
most likely
do we have plans to counter all of the
possible responses
how effective will our counters be
what does this action mean for the
long-term stability of iraq
and the trillions of dollars and
thousands of american lives
sacrificed there
how does the administration plan to
manage
an escalation of hostilities and how
does the administration plan to avoid a
larger
and potentially endless conflagration
in the middle east these are questions
that must be answered it is my view
that the president does not have the
authority for a war
with iran if he plans a large increase
in troops
and potential hostility over a longer
time
the administration will require
congressional approval
and the approval of the american people
the president's decision may add to an
already dangerous
and difficult situation in the middle
east
the risk of a much longer military
engagement in the middle east is acute
and immediate this action
may well have brought our nation closer
to another endless war
exactly the kind of endless war the
president promised
he would not drag us into
as our citizens and those of our allies
evacuate iraq and troops prepare for
retaliatory action
congress needs answers to these
questions and others
from the administration immediately
and the american people need answers
as well on impeachment
mr president the senate begins this new
session of congress
preparing to do something that has
happened only twice
twice before in american history serving
as a court of impeachment
in a trial of the president of the
united states
donald trump stands accused by the house
of representatives of committing one of
the offenses
the founding fathers most feared
when it came to the stability of the
republic
abusing the powers of his office for
personal gain
soliciting the interference of a foreign
power
in our elections to benefit himself
the house has also charged the president
with obstructing congress in the
investigation into those matters
the consequence of an unprecedented
blockade of relevant witnesses and
documents
flatly denying the legislative branch's
constitutional authority
to provide oversight of the executive
as all eyes turn to the senate the
question before us
is will we fulfill our duty to conduct
a fair impeachment trial of the
president of the united states
or will we not that
is the most pressing question facing the
senate
at the outset of this second session of
the 116th congress
will we conduct a fair trial that
examines all the facts
or not the country just saw senator
mcconnell's answer to that question
his answer is no instead of trying to
find the truth
he is still using the same feeble
talking points that he was using last
december
the country just saw how the republican
leader views his responsibility at this
pivotal moment in our nation's history
the republican leader prefers
finger-pointing and name-calling
to avoid answering the looming question
why shouldn't the senate call witnesses
the republican leader hasn't given one
good reason
why there shouldn't be relevant
witnesses or relevant documents
we did not hear one from leader
mcconnell today
or any day once again
leader mcconnell tried to bury his
audience under an avalanche of partisan
recriminations
and misleading references to precedents
there is
only one precedent that matters here
that never never in the history of our
country
has there been an impeachment trial of
the president
in which the senate was denied the
ability to hear from witnesses
let me repeat that that is the salient
fact here
there isn't there is only one precedent
that matters
there has never never in the history of
our country
been an impeachment trial of the
president in which the senate was denied
the ability
to hear from witnesses yet the
republican leader
seems intent on violating that precedent
and denying critical evidence to this
body
and to the american people
leader mcconnell has been clear and
vocal that he has no intention to be
impartial in this process
leader mcconnell reminds us today and in
previous days
that rather than acting like a judge and
a juror he intends to act as the
executioner
of a fair trial thankfully
the rules of the impeachment trial will
be determined by the majority of
senators in this chamber
not by the republican leader alone
the crux of the issue still is whether
the senate will hear testimony
from witnesses and receive documentary
evidence
directly relevant to the charges against
the president
since congress recessed for the holidays
there have been several
several events that have significantly
bolstered my argument for four specific
witnesses
and specific categories of documents
nothing
nothing in that time has bolstered
leader mcconnell's argument
that there shouldn't be relevant
witnesses or documents
on december 21st the center for public
integrity obtained emails through a
freedom of information act request
that showed that michael duffy a top omb
official and one of the four witnesses
i've requested
asked the defense department to quote
hold off
on sending military aid to ukraine 91
minutes
after president trump's july phone call
with ukrainian president zielenski
on december 29th the new york times
report included
several revelations about the extent of
chief mulvaney's involvement in the
delayed military assistance
about the effort by lawyers at omb
justice and the white house
to create legal justifications for the
delay in assistance
and about the depth of opposition to
and indeed alarm about the delay in
military assistance
from parts of the administration
particularly
the pentagon then just yesterday there
was a new report
about a trove of newly unredacted emails
that further exposed the serious
concerns
raised by trump administration officials
about the propriety and legality of the
president's decision
to delay military assistance to ukraine
one of those emails were released
yesterday was from michael duffy
one of the witnesses we've requested to
the pentagon controller and it read
quote clear direction from potus the
president
to continue the hold clear direction
from the president to continue the hold
is what duffy wrote what constituted
clear direction
did michael duffy get an order from the
president
or did someone like mr mulvaney get an
order from the president that was passed
on to mr duffy
were there discussions by administration
officials
about covering up the reasons for the
president directing the delay in
military assistance
these are questions that can only be
answered
by examination of the documentary
documentary evidence
and by the testimony of key trump
administration
officials under oath in a senate trial
these developments are a devastating
blow
to leader mcconnell's push to have a
trial without
the documents and witnesses we've
requested
each new revelation mounts additional
pressure on the members of this chamber
to seek the whole truth with these new
emails
we're getting certain portions of the
truth we need the whole truth
for example much of the evidence that
was obtained by the recent foia requests
has been heavily redacted
here is an email chain between officials
at the pentagon
regarding the politico article
that first revealed the trump
administration was delaying military
assistance to ukraine
it is completely redacted every word
crossed out not available can't be seen
here's another email with the subject
line apportionment
between officials at omb and the
pentagon
completely redacted none of the words
can be seen
at all
we know now that some of these
redactions were covered up
but only some of it why did they redact
the
sections they redacted who ordered the
redactions
why are they covering up what are they
hiding
these questions must be asked when you
are accused of something
you don't suppress evidence that will
exonerate you
the fact that the administration is
going to such lengths
to prevent such emails from coming out
is extraordinarily telling
it seems like they themselves feel they
are guilty
getting the full documentary record
would undoubtedly shed light on the
issues at hand
these were senior trump officials
discussing the delay in military
assistance to ukraine
who ordered it why it was ordered
whether or not it was legal and how it
was connected
to the effort to pressure ukraine into
announcing investigations
regarding a political rival of the
president
and these emails represent just a sliver
of the documentary evidence that exists
in this case
there was an exceedingly strong case to
call witnesses and request documents
before the senate went out of session
for the christmas break in the short
time since
that case has gotten stronger and
remarkably so
we are not asking for critics of the
president to serve as witnesses in the
trial
we are asking only that the president's
men his top
advisers tell their side of the story
and leader mcconnell once again
has been unable to make one argument one
single argument as to why these
witnesses
and these documents should not be part
of a trial now i want to respond to one
suggestion by leader mcconnell
that we follow the 199 1999 example of
beginning the impeachment trial first
and then deciding on witnesses and
documents at a later date
first to hear mcconnell say no witnesses
now but
maybe some later is just another
indication
he has no argument against witnesses and
documents on the merits
will leader mcconnell commit
to witnesses and documents now and
discuss
timing later second
leader mcconnell's comparisons to 1999
are hopelessly flawed and
inaccurate there were witnesses in 1999
leader mcconnell
you want the president of 1999 there
were witnesses
as there were in every single
impeachment trial of the president
in history it would be a break in
president
precedent for their not to be witnesses
third there was even a greater rationale
for witnesses in the clinton trial
in 1999 the witnesses in question had
already testified they had
already testified under oath extensively
and there were also bipartisan concerns
about the suitability of the subject
matter
for the floor of the senate there's no
analogy to today's situation
the witnesses we've requested never
testified under oath
and the documents we've requested have
not been produced
fourth we have a tradition in america of
a
fair and speedy trial that's why we've
requested only the relevant information
up front so that the trial can truly be
speedy and fair
it makes no sense and in fact it is a
ruse
to suggest that the senate wait until
the end of the trial
to settle the hardest question when it
might take
time for witnesses to prepare testimony
and for the senate to review new
document documentary evidence
we can and should begin that process now
and ensure that the trial is informed by
the facts
and does not suffer unnecessary delays
fifth and finally
when leader mcconnell suggests we have
both sides present their arguments and
then deal with witnesses
he is essentially proposing to conduct
the whole trial
and then once the trial is basically
over
consider the question of evidence that
makes no sense
that's alice in wonderland logic the
trial must be informed by the evidence
not the other way around
the house manager should be allowed to
present all of the evidence to make
their case
not make their case and then afterward
ask for evidence we know is out there
so if we don't get a commitment up front
that the house managers will be able to
call witnesses
as part of their case the senate will
act as little more
than a nationally televised meeting of
the mock
trial club if we leave the wit
the question of witnesses and documents
until after all the presentations are
complete
leader mcconnell will argue that the
senate's heard enough
we shouldn't prolong the trial any
longer at that point
you can be sure he'll label anyone who
wants to subpoena evidence as a partisan
who wants to drag the whole affair out i
know this be
because we've he's already told us what
his position will be this is not a
mystery
quote after we've heard the arguments
leader mcconnell said on fox news we
ought to vote and move on
does that sound like someone in good
faith
who intends to have the senate
reasonably consider witnesses
at a later date no it does not
leader mcconnell's proposal to vote on
witnesses and documents later
is nothing more than a poorly disguised
trap
after we've heard the arguments leader
mcconnell said
we ought to vote and move on all
of my fellow senators democrat and
republican
should take stock of the leader's words
and remember the commitment he made on
national television
to take his cues from the white house
so i say to the chair it may feel like
we are no longer
we are no closer to establishing the
rules for a senate trial
than when we last met but the question
the vital question of whether or not we
have a fair trial
ultimately rests with a majority of the
senators in this chamber
the president faces gravely serious
charges
abuse of power abuse of his public trust
soliciting the interference of a foreign
power in our elections
unprecedented obstruction of congress
and if convicted the president faces the
most severe punishment
our constitution imagines
the framers gave us this chamber
the united states senate the sole power
to discharge this most difficult and
sombra judy
will the senate rise to the occasion
i yield the floor
the chair recognizes the distinguished
senator from maryland
thank you mr president
i start by thanking senator schumer
the minority leader for his pursuit
of a fair impeachment trial here in the
united states senate
something supported by the overwhelming
majority of the american people
whether they be republicans democrats
or independents and the senate
will soon undertake this most serious
of its duties considering the
impeachment of a president
none of us relish this moment but we all
have a solemn responsibility
under the constitution to try this case
to assess the evidence and render a fair
judgment we will hear a case from the
house of representatives
and from the president's lawyers and we
will first be sworn in
to do quote impartial justice
according to the constitution and the
laws
unquote mr president while senators are
primarily
expected to listen to the evidence
and weigh that evidence we also have a
special ability
that most juries do not have we can
request
additional information we can request
witnesses we can request
documents and it only takes a simple
majority
51 senators to call witnesses
and request those documents
and in the two other times in the
history of the senate
when we have considered a presidential
impeachment
we have required witnesses to testify
directly or give
sworn depositions in president clinton's
impeachment trial
three witnesses were deposed even though
they had
all given prior sworn testimony
in related proceedings at that time
now majority leader mcconnell called
their request for testimony
quote modest a modest request
mr president senate democrats have
another
modest request that's pending today
we would like to hear from four
witnesses who have not testified
previously who did not testify
in the house who have not testified
under penalty of perjury
like we saw other house witnesses
testify and why is that that is because
president trump has ordered them
not to testify those four witnesses
are white house acting chief of staff
mick mulvaney
former national security adviser john
bolton and top
administration officials michael duffy
and robert blair
we are also asking the senate to request
key documents
that the president has refused to
provide
we know these are
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
you